the plastic bags produced in Edmond
sayers factory are sold across the
Middle East he has a workforce of 50 and
the factory runs day and night but it
only gets electricity from the grid for
a few hours a day generators at the
factory provide the rest we need lots of
diesel the big 640 kilowatt generator
uses 80 litres an hour or more than 1500
liters a day that much fuel costs
between 12 and 13 thousand dollars every
day
burning 1 liter of diesel fuel results
in emissions of about 3 kilograms of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
Munsell would like to switch to clean
energy a new project involves setting up
green energy generation systems linking
them up to the grid and installing a net
metering system to track the flows of
electricity if you feed green energy
into the grid you get credits so you can
later take the same amount of energy
from the grid energy from renewable
sources helps make the system more
stable reducing the frequency of power
outages the United Nations Development
Agency set up the project called Sidra
its engineers have drawn up a wind map
of Lebanon to identify the best
locations for new wind turbines it's a
very good solution first it gives you
electricity and then it really reduce
your co2 emissions and you save the
environment a number of schools are
involved in the project their solar
panels light the classrooms on sunny
days excess energy goes into the grid
earning the school's credits for cloudy
days then they can draw power from the
grid as long as there's no outage before
we have this system we used to have our
own generator which caused a lot and
most of the neighbors here they ask me
what's this and what we use it for and
they are very you know eager to do such
a project a few weeks earlier engineers
involved in the project attended a
seminar in Berlin it was about the
integration of wind and solar energy
into the grid how it can make the grid
more stable the latest technology and
associated problems makes us see what is
possible and it helps us set as well
steps into how to achieve the goals
we've set so the technology we've taken
I mean the knowledge we have seen here
this photovoltaic system on a high-rise
in Beirut is connected to the grid and a
net metering system has been installed
when the Sun shines electricity costs
decline and now they rarely have to fire
up the diesel generator